hey everyone today's topic is python
developer
jobs skills and resuming so while we're
at it if you haven't subscribed to our
channel already
go ahead and click on the subscribe
button and hit the bell icon to never
miss an update
so here is the agenda for the session
first
we will go through the quick intro to
python
then we will understand who exactly a
python developer
is after that we will go through the
skill set of a python developer the job
roles that are suitable for python
developers
the current salary trends of a python
developer in the tech industry
and in the end we will have a look at
the resume of a python developer
to get insights into real-world
credibility and employability of a
python developer
so without further ado let's get started
introduction to python so let's quickly
go through this very concise python
intro
python is an interpreted high-level
interactive
object-oriented scripting language
python is very versatile in nature
and therefore its applications are
spread to various fields in the
industries
more popularly in web development
machine learning and ai and game
development
so who is a python developer let's
answer this
so here are some of the technologies
used by a python developer
pandas anaconda tensorflow python ides
django web framework and python
a python developer is one who develops
backend components of a web application
using
python when working as a web developer
now the web
frameworks like django and flask are
used for this purpose
a python developer is also the one who
writes effective testable and scalable
python code
he also performs data analysis when
working in the field of data science
so basically a python developer develops
deploys debugs and maintains a project
so let's go through the skill set of a
python developer
now the core python skills that a python
developer possesses
are data structures like arrays list
stack cues trees and graphs
there's oop concepts like inheritance
classes and objects and abstraction
thus packages and functions that is
importing external packages into a
python code
database and its connection that is
connecting a python backend to a
database like mysql
when it comes to data science skills
there's numpy
that is a library for performing
mathematical calculations
there's pandas that is the library for
storing and manipulating data
efficiently
there's sci-fi and then there's
matplotlib which is a library for
plotting charts and graphs for a given
data
and finally there are machine learning
algorithms which consists of models like
supervised learning unsupervised etc
now coming to web developer skills there
are frameworks like django and flask for
back-end development of web applications
and then there's web scraping which
includes taking data from websites and
converting that data
into usable format there's api handling
which is basically handling api requests
for a web application
to perform server side operations and
finally there is back-end connection
which basically involves the back-end
part of a web application
and is usually handled by python
frameworks
now moving on let's look at the python
developer job roles
first up is python web developer now a
python web developer
usually writes server site code works on
the web frameworks like django and flask
collaborates with the data team to
gather end users requirements
develops the server-side platform
deploys applications
performs tuning usability improvement
and automation
moving on next job role is data analyst
now a data analyst generally works on
python libraries
including matplotlib numpy pandas etc
carry out data analysis collect data
using the scripting language
explore data sets gather requirements
tune in applications analyze problems
communicate findings with the team or
stakeholders
the next job role is automation test
engineer
now an automation test engineer usually
works on python test
framework tools including pi test pi
unit
perform complex system tests
troubleshoot code issues
create test scripts design the
automation
framework perform a b testing
next up is machine learning engineer
now a machine learning engineer has the
following roles
to perform statistical analysis of data
put machine learning models into
production research and transform data
science prototypes
research and implement appropriate ml
algorithms
and tools perform ml tests
and keep updated with the ml trends
the last job role is software engineer
now a software engineer is expected to
write server side code
collaborate with the design team to
gather end users requirements
develop the server-side platform deploy
applications
perform tuning usability improvement and
automation
moving on to the next topic let's look
at the python developer salary trends
now software engineers with python
skills are offered better salaries
across the globe
the average salary of a python developer
in india
is around 7 lakhs 55 000 rupees per
annum
the average salary of a python developer
in the us is about 79
000 us dollars per annum
moving on to our last segment python
developer resuming
so let's go ahead and understand what a
python developer resume should portray
just keep a few things in mind when
you're preparing your resume
your resume should be clear updated and
concise
you should prioritize the skills
according to the job role you're
applying for
and do not write anything extra that's a
big no
the recruiters are smart enough to know
that so do not
lie and do not write extra firstly let's
look at the pressure resuming
so if you're refresher these are some of
the points that you need to know
first you have the resume header now the
summary is supposed to be clear and
concise
just say what exactly you want and some
of your strengths
next is the profile links and your
portfolio so you can mention your
linkedin profile link and also your
github repository link if you have
next up is the projects now clearly
depict the goal of your project so
just in case you worked on let's see
five projects make sure you keep it
concise and crisp
next up is your education do not lie
here make sure you give
a relevant education with grades next
you have the certifications if you have
any certifications or achievements go
ahead and
write them down next you have the
technical skills now again
prioritize according to the job role and
lastly you have your non-technical
skills this could be your communication
analytical skills problem solving skills
etc
moving on to an experienced developer so
again mention the resume header
then you have the summary again very
crisp and clear go ahead and mention
your portfolios
and your links coming to experience now
here you have to clearly depict your
work you will have to make sure that you
write down all your responsibilities
in that company do not go overboard and
write extra
keep it very concise again relevant
education and your grades
you have technical skills the same goes
for this as well
prioritize according to the job role and
finally you have your non-technical
skills
so there you go by now you must be aware
of all the skills and job
responsibilities of a python developer
and i'm sure you're ready to build your
resume for the next interview
we also have a python youtube playlist
that covers
everything from the basics to advanced
python concepts
don't forget to check that out if you're
interested in python development
the link is added in the description box
below so with that
we've reached the end of this video i
hope you liked it
do you think we missed out on anything
important let us know in the chat
section
or in the comment section so thank you
so much for watching the video
we'll be back with another live video
soon until then
keep learning and stay tuned to simply
learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd up and get certified
click here